[Musique]
monsieur berrios bienvenu merci d'être
avec nous sur rt france alors une lettre
ouverte au gouvernement pourquoi
bonjour l'écouté tout est dans la lettre
tout est dans le titre c'est à dire si
la marche forcée qui nous pose un
problème les élus locaux les maires sont
toujours bénévoles en ont fait toujours
en sorte que les choses fonctionnent le
mieux surtout d'aller de crise je vais
dire que c'est même presque d'essence de
travail de maire mais ça n'a néanmoins à
marche forcée dans des conditions
sanitaires que l'on connaît sa porte ce
fait porter des risques importants pas à
seulement mère ça fait porter aussi des
risques importants aux enseignants aux
enfants et aux parents pour cause les
choses se passent bien il faut du bon
sens et l'urgence n'est pas bonne
conseillère lorsqu'il s'agit de crises
sanitaires
il faut le faire avec tout le sérieux la
rigueur possible est une des premières
choses que nous devons savoir s est
important c'est combien d'enseignants
seront là le jour j
pourquoi cette question est pourquoi
est-ce qu'on commence par là à s'amender
fossé il ya par exemple six mille cinq
cents enfants
c'est un mensonge que de dire que 6500
enfants seront étudie le jour j on sait
déjà que ce sera au mieux un sur deux
laissez un sur deux ce sera au mieux
si l'ensemble des enseignants seront la
mesure est bien dans ces conditions que
le dispositif nécessaire pour accueillir
les enfants des balles de même si on est
exactement à 1 sur 2 ou si on est à 20 %
des élèves et ce n'est pas la même chose
si les enseignants sont là aussi
d'enseignants ne sont pas là de la même
façon que ce protocole doit s'appliquer
dans toute sa rigueur sanitaires encore
une fois il s'agit pas d'un règlement
école par école il s'agit d'un règlement
sanitaire nationale il de vous impliquer
partout selon vous la réouverture des
écoles le 11 mai cela voudra dire que
les gestes barrière ne pourront pas être
respectés en tout cas que des règles
sanitaires seront pas effectives alors
selon vous qu'est ce qui a motivé la
décision de l'exécutif et qu'est ce qui
a poussé le gouvernement a annoncé la
réouverture des écoles dès le 11 mai je
vous a bondi ce n'est pas que ce n'est
pas possible ce que nous disons c'est
qu'il nous faut du temps parce que école
par école
les situations ne sont pas identiques
vous pouvez avoir des classes de 80 m²
d'autres de 40 mètres carrés peut avoir
des classes qui peut accueillir 15
élèves d'autres qui ne pourront en
accueillir que 10 vous avez des
municipalités qui sont capables de
mobiliser beaucoup de personne d'autre
qui ne sont pas capables voulu mobiliser
beaucoup de personnes quelle sera la
présence des enseignants qui est un
élément quand même important et tout
cela nous devons le faire dans l'urgence
et c'est ça qui pose problème
le protocole sanitaire nous avons reçu
on est aujourd'hui lundi on a reçu
dimanche soir à 20 heures et on doit
tout mettre en place
en quatre jours parce que l'antre des
classes c'est le 11 et que vendredi est
férié je pense que le bon sens commande
une progressivité et d'accepter avec les
choses en soit ainsi et je ne pense pas
d'ailleurs que le gouvernement dira
votre show dans sa réponse mais qui nous
apportera alors on l'a dit rapidement il
ya des sénateurs lr qui vont
certainement saisir le conseil
constitutionnel selon eux trop de
responsabilités un pèse sur les mères
sur les élus locaux est maire de
saint-maur défense et en banlieue
parisienne
qu'est ce que vous en pensez est ce que
l'exécutif fait trop poser de
responsabilité sur vos épaules nous
avons depuis le début de la crise une
façon générale d'ailleurs sur nos
épaules des restos bilité quotidienne
minute par minute au son soulève le
matin on a annoncé qu'on assimile sens à
sa mort par exemple un g6 mise à 100
enfants qui rentrent à l'école qui sont
autant de risque pénal pour moi donc ce
n'est pas une nouveauté en revanche ce
que nous souhaitons c'est de le faire en
conscience en étant sûr d'apporter le
meilleur service
les garanties sanitaires aux enfants
c'est ça que l'on souhaite
et pour ça il nous faut un peu plus de
temps ce n'est pas contre gouvernement
ce n'est pas des mesures contre les
confinant c'est simplement des mesures
de bon sens nous sommes dans un moment
un peu d'urgence parce que le
dégonflement a été fixée au 11 mai sont
pas les maires qu'ils ont fixées xt 11
même où très bien on prend la date on a
adressé un protocole sanitaire
hier soir donc dimanche à 20h la mesure
et qu'en quatre jours ont fait pas
rentrer des centaines de milliers
d'élèves
c'est une c du bon sens et je pense que
le gouvernement ira dans le sens de ce
que nous disons c'est à dire on peut le
faire de façon progressive de telle
sorte à ce que personne ne soit lésé et
surtout pas la sécurité des enfants
sylvain bernier hausse merci d'avoir
répondu à nos questions je rappelle que
vous êtes maire de saint maur des fossés
en banlieue parisienne merci d'avoir
être en direct avec nous